this is a very direct question did your
client
hand the gun to alec baldwin first of
all i wasn't there
no what did he tell you
what did he tell you he's in shock i
mean he's having a hard time sorting so
you're saying he doesn't know whether or
not he handed the gun to alec baldwin is
that what you're telling us right now he
doesn't know if he handed it to me no of
course
no i'm not saying that
the attorney for assistant director dave
halls challenged eyewitness accounts and
sworn affidavits in a tense exchange on
fox news in the affidavits it states
that my client grabbed the gun off of a
prop cart and handed it to baldwin
that absolutely did not happen
hall's attorney seemed to put the blame
on the film's armorer hana gutierrez
reid i have received information from
crew members that
the armor handed it directly to baldwin
in a statement to e.t hall said he is
shocked and saddened by helena hutchins
death
meanwhile it was a tough day for alec
and his family the family cat emilio
went missing alex's wife ellaria put out
an alert on instagram this morning less
than five hours after ellaria put the
word out she posted emilio had been
found although he seems to have a broken
leg
earlier a source told e.t elaria is very
concerned about alec and his well-being
during what has been an extraordinarily
difficult time for their family i'm not
allowed to comment on the investigation
i talk to the cops every day
now there are emerging reports that the
let me say protocol was somewhat
lackadaisical
if not ignored on the set
camera assistant lane looper told the la
times it always felt like the budget was
more important than crew members he says
there were multiple accidental
discharges of firearms on set one
involving alex stunt double and another
when a woman in the props department
shot herself in the foot with a blank
round e.t with crimeonline.com founder
nancy grace multiple people handling
weapons and again these are not all pop
guns these are real
guns
[Music]